welcome to the show tonight we are a
full hour on baby prudence the child who
was abducted yesterday
we have the 911 call and the last taken
home video of baby pru
we have reporters in the field as
hundreds of people
are searching for what's that they found
her she's fine we'll [ __ ]
me
[Music]
and we have breaking news baby lakeisha
has gone missing for the next hour we
will watch that nobody cares
moving on let's check in with baby
prudence her 14th day home
and she's still safe and sound
[Music]
hello everybody out there this is brock
favors with traffic on the ones chad
armstrong
is out sick today so i am filling in for
my usual land reports
and uh i'm up here in the chopper but i
gotta tell you guys
i am loving the view
oh my god oh oh no
oh
all right well we are um uh
we are over the 10. it is massively
clogged down there like a pint of maple
syrup on a cool november morning
[Music]
okay okay i am uh
i am very sorry folks there's a little
bit of a bumpy ride up here
we are now approaching the and where the
left lane
is blocked by a mattress so somebody is
uh
going to be doing a little return to
ikea later today
oh goddamn oh get me on this
oh
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm very sorry folks
i'm very sorry but but i'm losing my
head up here
actually you have every right too we're
about to crash
[Music]
rick nicholsbee reporting live from a
gruesome scene a cult known as qet
or quest for eternal truth has
apparently taken their own lives in a
mass suicide
police confirmed that cyanide-laced
cherry kool-aid was also on the premises
excuse me hi rick nicholsbee channel six
hi are you two from the neighborhood
oh yes
yeah okay were you two members of the
cult that lived here the co
what cult was this a coho i had no idea
this was a cult why
well i'd say the term cult is a little
judgmental i would say the same thing
yeah not knowing the full doctrine
well apparently they believed that there
was a spaceship waiting for them behind
the moon
okay well you know that that still is
really possible and it's possible right
i mean
who knows what is out there in the
universe okay well it appears they
killed themselves in order to board the
ship right and that's where we disagreed
with them right there or would have we
would have disagreed with them
had we been there on on our departure
day their departure day their departure
day
which is the day that they did this i
mean that's what you could call it if
you wanted to
i ain't in no cult no i mean what i
always wondered is
how or am starting to wonder since you
brought this
to our attention why if there was a
spaceship in the sky
why wouldn't it just beam up beam them
up right sisters
just beam them up why can't you just
beat them up alive why you got to be
dead to get beamed up
you know i've been saying that for weeks
seconds for seconds
because because you rick nichols b you
told us that
uh you know and that's how i knew
because seconds like 50 seconds ago you
said it
i didn't know anything about it until
you would said it because i ain't in no
code okay well then why would someone
join a cult
character leadership nick you know like
a compelling
person i mean hypothetically they could
have had tacos on tuesday
which would have been a draw i mean that
would have been a plus okay so
this is a tragic day for this community
and for the members of the
quest for earthly truth i'm rick
nicholsbee
you reporting yep you see everybody chop
the gun
we're ready evening st
paul it's your city news at five i'm
jamie throneberg and i'm
marcy whitchurch winter weather
advisories are in effect across central
minnesota tonight with more on that
weatherman isaac labuda isaac
thanks marcie a major system is zipping
across the region
outside temp right now eight degrees but
it feels like 20 below
jamie well stay off the roads if you can
folks lots of reports of black ice
you got to watch out for that dangerous
black ice it's transparent and sneaky
hard to see black eyes that's right
marcy keep your loved ones safe and
warn them to stay off the streets
tonight because of menacing life-robbing
black
black ice isaac
we have channel 17's field reporter
darren hempner with more
erin yeah
[Music]
i'm standing out here in historic ramsey
hill where there are currently no cars
on the street due to
uh hazardous driving conditions
darren are you talking about black ice
that's right jesus it's frightening just
to even say
black ice it's scary tricky ruthless
stuff that black ice
a perfectly safe neighborhood can be
suddenly terrorized by the appearance of
black ice
well one must keep in mind that
just because black ice looks different
than white ice it doesn't make it any
more dangerous
also one must remember how hard it is
for black
ice to survive what with the authorities
trying to destroy it
with the snow plows and the salt trucks
but
black ice perseveres that's right that's
right
and as you can see right now the city is
being controlled by lots of oppressive
white snow making it hard for all people
to advance and we don't hear much news
about that now do we no we do not well
thank you very much
brother darren but let's be honest black
ice is the real menace
last night i was in a perfectly safe
neighborhood
walking away from an atm machine when
black ice just snuck up on me and
practically robbed me of
my balance ouch that sounds exactly like
something black ice would do
well i just hope that folks watch out so
the white snow
doesn't blind them and keep them from
seeing what's really going on
all i'm saying is i can't think of a
single christmas song about black ice
lots of cheerful uplifting songs about
snow so
well for the record black ice never
asked to be out here
no it did not it's a product of the
environment
in fact black ice didn't land on the
road
the road landed on black ice hey
man okay
next up why is america being ruined by
black people
[Music]
what do we do they told us at the
station to come down here and fill time
but uh
there's no story here in this
neighborhood there's always a story
here give me the name of a mythical
creature mythical cr i don't trust me uh
i don't know
pegasus pegasus perfect just roll
watch and learn nobody can stay in my
house if they want to
hi there rick nicklesby channel six news
we've had reports of a pegasus in the
area has anybody seen anything like that
oh yeah man i've seen the pegasus i've
seen it every day yeah
man we both see that pegasus yeah i
started with my own two eyes man
that horse had a big old snakehead on
top of it ain't got no snakehead fool
y'all that hey that horse had some big
wings
curiosity has brought out large crowds
to see the alleged pegasus in this south
lennox neighborhood oh look there it is
i'm gonna find it break it
and then ride it to the pegasus treasure
residents say the creature resembles
this
amateur sketch kick the [ __ ] out my car
city's gotta pay for that
too i ain't got no coverage with no
pegasus [ __ ] he landed on my roof man
look at my roof man he busted it up he
busted the whole thing up man
yeah he been here he been sitting up
there every day while many revel in the
possibility of
seeing the winged horse others are not
so welcoming i
i just know this neighborhood will be
better if that pegasus
is put down i tell you this god ain't
putting our wings on no horse
now see if this was a white neighborhood
animal control would be up in here
with a pegasus trap that's right they
can't take our pegasus this is all
pegasus up in his mother hey man why are
you interrupting me
i'm trying to talk about the pegasus
don't be disrespecting the packages
yes we're here live on the scene in
south lennox where riots have broken out
over the alleged appearance of a flying
horse
brock favors here filling in for a chad
armstrong who
is out sick today we are here live at
the metro police department
canine training facility and we are
going to be learning
some apprehension techniques used by the
k-9 unit now
officer hanson uh i will be playing the
assailant today is that correct
yeah that's correct now officer hanson i
am perfectly safe in this suit right
yeah you're 100 safe in fact those are
the uh suits we use for officer training
all right well there you go well kids
make sure that you do not try this at
home with your chihuahuas
okey dokey i am sorry
that uh you all just uh heard me use
that inappropriate language that was
very uncalled for
when you panic like that yeah he thinks
you're more of a threat than you are
that's when he's gonna bite down harder
okay well i will
make an effort this time to really try
and and
be as calm as possible even though it is
very difficult to be calm
when you're in the lion's den or should
i say the dog you're dead
[Music]
the mood is infectious and exciting
today as people from all walks of life
celebrate becoming the seventh state to
legalize gay marriage
we're here talking to excited couples
about how they feel on this historic
day oh hi hi hi uh yeah it's a very
historic day for civil rights
and for gay americans and americans all
over the country
we're gonna get married
we said that to be a conversation you
know what i mean because we didn't know
this was gonna pass
so darn fast so are you guys a couple
are we a couple come on girl let's get
serious
my name is lashon and this right here is
my sandwich
it's a samuel yeah and we're gonna get
married
that's so great how long have you guys
been together well we've been three
years
it's been forever we've been waiting
forever it's really important to know
the person
who is the bride i am the bride
[Applause]
well tell us all about your plans um
well you know we never thought it was
important to have a piece of paper so
there's not any plans in there
we go and get that piece of paper
centered
where do you think you guys will get
married oh we know there's a lot of
hidden costs in a way everywhere
we gonna get married over here and over
there and in the sky and on a cloud
oh it sounds like it's gonna be a big
wedding well you know uh yeah it's
it's it's a conference we're gonna rent
the moon and fill it with rosie
we really need to talk about whether or
not we think it's fair to even get
married when it's still illegal in so
many other states
see look at him look at him that's my
man with his big hearts
i'm sorry my husband you're my husband
now well we're just my husband now
okay we just don't want to rush into
anything because stuff gets overturned
remember what happened in california
baby i won't get a 14
carat ring the size of 14 mother carrots
that's what's up doc well you two
certainly seem excited yeah do we seem
excited yeah okay
congratulations i hope you guys have a
wonderful life together just we really
just didn't think it was gonna pass it's
gonna be
we're gonna have a house that's shaped
like a unicorn and we're gonna have five
little girls the name's gonna be
ethni carousel sequin abercrombie and
phantom
and we're gonna have a little dog named
ruffalo and the dog gonna have a cat
named myriad
police say late last night they
apprehended rodney gullivan
and found a gun and narcotics in his
truck he was charged with possession and
assault on his fiancee
and she is in the hospital recovering
tonight meanwhile another woman was
sexually assaulted by benjamin braider
of indianapolis
the unidentified woman suffered a broken
rib and a split lip
she's in stable condition tonight well
that's it for sports
[Music]
chuck